-Julia and I are about to face
off in a game of "Box of Lies."
All right, here's how it works.
Upstage are nine mystery boxes
containing objects no one
has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick up a box,
take out the object,
and describe it
to your opponent.
They have to guess if you're
lying or telling the truth.
We'll play three rounds.
Julia, why don't
you pick the first box.
-Why, thank you very much.
I shall.
-You're welcome. Yes.
Oh, 4.
-Okay. I don't know.
-The game has already begun.
-I'm very excited.
-It looks medium weight.
You didn't struggle, really,
carrying it over,
so it's not heavy.
All right. Okay.
-Okay.
-Don't cheat.
-I'm not cheating at all.
I feel like
you're cheating already.
-I'm not cheating.
-Yeah, well, you were,
like, confused at first,
and then you're amused.
-You're starting to irritate me.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, so...
Let me explain something to you.
-Yeah.
-You're familiar with something
that's -- A closet, right?
A closet?
-Yeah. Am I familiar
with a closet?
Yeah, sure.
I've never heard of that.
What does that word mean?
-Hang on, hang on.
And in this closet,
which is miniature, obviously,
there is a horse.
-Okay.
-And it has a huge collection --
Who thinks these up, by the way?
-Well, right now, I think
you're thinking this up.
-You don't know
what I'm about to say.
A huge collection
of sandals and high heels?
-Okay. Okay.
-And -- Yeah, like, wait.
-Oh, my goodness.
Yeah, 4, 5, 6.
-No, no, no.
I'm looking at the rooms.
-You're counting.
You have the 4, 5, 6,
high heels, and sandals.
Give me a break.
You're talking about shoes,
because from the interview,
you were talking about shoes,
and now it's in your head.
-No, I wasn't.
-Yes, you were
talking about high heels
for the Mark Twain thing.
So let me tell you
something -- you lie!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Ding ]
-Oh!
You know, I've got to
tell you something.
I really pride myself
on being a good liar,
so I'm incredibly
upset right now.
-Oh, I thought you were
going to say impressed.
I thought you were going to
say impressed.
-No!
-Guys, what number
shall I choose?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
There is no 11.
3. Okay.
Somebody yelled "11."
There is no 11.
Thank you, though.
[ Straining ]
-Oh, it must be heavy.
Wow. That looks so, so heavy.
You poor thing.
Your arms are killing you.
Yeah.
-My arms are killing me.
Here we go here.
And that's a...
Abbondanza.
Okay.
-Yeah.
-I feel like I should just
tell you the truth,
because sometimes the truth is
funnier than fiction.
-Right, but this is called
"Box of Lies," just F.Y.I.
Anyway, carry on.
-Well, it's two contestants from
"The Masked Singer"
in a tiny hot tub
filled with Jell-O.
-Two contestants from what?
-"The Masked Singer,"
the show --
The mystery singers on Fox
with the giant bee heads
and alien heads.
-First of all, note to self --
I have to watch that show.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're missing out.
It's over already.
You missed it.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-Let me tell you something.
I think that you --
I think you're
telling me the truth.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh, come on.
[ Buzzer ]
-This is the best game
I've ever played.
Ever!
I've never been this good.
-I hate this game!
-I'm usually terrible
at this game.
This is great!
-Can I go now?
-We're doing one more round.
This one is worth 10,000 points.
-Okay, you guys...
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Can -- Wait a minute.
Can everybody please
just speak once at a time?
-Yeah.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-2? 2.
-So, here we go.
-Okay.
-I'm hot.
-I got to get to 2.
-You can't get me.
I'm hot, man! I'm hot!
Ow-wah!
Oh, it's really heavy.
Oh, my God. Oh, my goodness.
It's really so heavy.
Oh, look at how
exhausted you are.
Oh, my God.
-Actually, it's quite light.
-Oh, it is.
-Okay.
-Oh, it's light? Okay. Wow.
Now, I don't know if
that was a lie or true.
Okay. Okay.
How are you? Everything good?
-Are you familiar
with something...
-This is how you play the game?
Am I familiar with a closet?
Yes.
-Something called a paintbrush?
-Yes, of course.
-Okay.
And...
[ Laughs ]
And have you
ever braided your hair?
Or your wife's hair
or your daughter's hair?
-Yes.
-Okay, so, what this is
a paintbrush of hair
that's been braided with --
What do you call that thing?
A ponytail holder at the end.
-Like, a scrunchie?
-No, it's not.
I said it's a ponytail holder.
Come on. Let's go.
-What's a ponytail holder?
I've never even heard of that.
Why didn't you say,
"Are you familiar
with ponytail holders?"
I'm not.
-You are not.
-I am not.
I have no idea what that means.
A ponytail holder?
-Well, it's like a thinner thing
that's not a scrunchie.
-A rubber band?
A rubber band?
-No, a ponytail holder.
A rubber band is made of rubber
and can tear your hair.
This is a ponytail holder.
-Made of fabric.
-It's also --
There's paint on it and also...
[ Laughter ]
I love this game.
Can I come back
and play again tomorrow?
-This is unbelievable.
Okay. Gosh.
-By all means, take your time.
-I'm going to say...you lie.
-Whoo!
-Oh, it worked!
[ Dinging ]
Oh, come on!
I was like,
"That's too descriptive.
That's too good."
Julia Louis-Dreyfus, everybody,
the champion!